già detto di dirmi la verità fa beh voi
a verità sia promeriggio racconterà b
pagata lo giuro e allora sì top credito
una coppia standard litiga di media
sette volte al giorno
a quanto pare non esiste passatempo che
ci diverta a parte avere ragione in un
litigio né mente secondo alcune persone
anche che ha colto marchio può ottenere
ragione
ecco sotto ben pensato di elencare
velocemente quelli che a parer mio sono
i trucchetti più utili per cadere sempre
in piena
l'ampliamento interpretare
l'affermazione dell'avversario nella sua
maniera più generale possibile terzi è
certo nuovo quest acqua malto scopata 30
anni senza siamo sposati
certo c'è una famiglia con questo
aspettiamo un bambino stanno a fare
nozze d'argento anti no quelle d'oro
esagerata ganz e hard la mia famiglia
pensa che tu non sia l'uomo giusto per
me l'immagine ti sei messo un perfetto
perché immagini sono c fusione chissà
quante reti un autografo di ruby e tu mi
stai diciamo che non abbiamo più soldi
perché gli hyper senso o no usare
sottili distinzioni o no non detto
questo ho detto solo capiamo ne pensa
alcuno se stai provando con quella
rincoglionire con una raffica di domande
o di me la cosa secondo te ogni ragazza
né bella modo suo mi è vero che anche
più c'è se possono trovare l'uomo alle
donne piace se corteggiate arcobaleno e
colorato che idea ha visto sono bando
dei fratelli una bando le croci oddio
non lo so ma allora che male certo
per tu con penso il pm la stoccata amore
per costruire il sesso con te fa cagare
le sue dimensioni non mi soddisfano più
parla d'altro amo a me pensatore colibrì
battono velocissimi le aninsei mazzante
non ha mai del tempo libero per me sei
una nazista ma cosa sei una nazista
volti moreno i bambini e sproloqui arma
amore i bambini sono belli se li trovi
nei pacchetti ed eva dati cioè sono
belli nella stanza al rav al santa
inquisizione race le streghe pensa pure
quanti diverso da un pochino in foto da
un bowl che il real è sempre con i tuoi
amici e insulta e tette piacevole come
in grappolo damon roidi personalmente
credo che esistano pochissime persone
per le quali valga la pena scomodarsi in
un litigio
ricordatevi che il grugnito di un maiale
risponde sempre un altro compito
piuttosto quali sono gli stratagemmi che
poi utilizzati per ottenere ragioni che
fate qualcosa
fatemi sapere in un commento un video
risposta non sms mms email analisi del
sangue quello che vi pare
ciao